DIED.
>> Martha: THAT'S THE "STORY" ON
JUNE 6th.
2019.
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
EVERY PRESIDENT SINCE GEORGE
WASHINGTON FACED POLITICAL
OPPOSITION.
DEMOCRACY ARE BUILT ON DEBATE
AND COMPETING IDEAS.
IF YOU FIND A POLITICAL LEADER
WHO SEEMS UNIVERSALLY LOVED YOU
HAVE FOUND A DICTATORSHIP.
AS A MATTER OF PRINCIPLE THERE
IS NOTHING WRONG WITH OPPOSING
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS POLICIES.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING FOR THE PAST 2.5
YEARS.
NOTHING ABOUT THE RESISTANCE
ENHANCED OUR DEMOCRACY OR MADE
THIS COUNTRY BETTER.
THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S SHREDDED DEMOCRATIC NOWHERE
ELSE.
THEY IMPOSED CENSORSHIP IS ON
MUCH OF THE COUNTRY AND SIDED
WITH THE BUREAUCRACY OVER
VOTERS.
LIKE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN UNDER VOTERS TO IGNORE
AND UNDERMINE THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S MORE DESTRUCTIVE THAN
ANYTHING THE RUSSIANS ATTEMPTED.
AT NBC NEWS HE DELIVERS
COMMENTARY.
>> IT'S TREASON.
IT'S A BETRAYAL OF THE NATION.
>> TREASON IS A BETRAYAL OF
TRUST AND AIDING AND ABETTING
THE ENEMY.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU DISAGREE
WITH JOHN BRENNAN, IT'S HIGH
TREASON.
THE DEATH PENALTY.
BRENNAN IS A RECKLESS AND
UNBALANCED PARTISAN.
WHEN WE LEARNED FROM A SOURCE
LAST YEAR THAT BRENNAN RETAINED
HIS TOP SECRET SECURITY
CLEARANCE AS A CIVILIAN WE WERE
SHOCKED BUT NOT SURPRISED.
BRENNAN NO LONGER WORKS FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND HOLDS NO
OFFICIAL POST.
ACCORDING TO TWO SOURCES WE
SPOKE TO TODAY, BRENNAN RETAINS
THE MOST VALUABLE ASSET HE HAD
IN GOVERNMENT.
A TOP SECRET SECURITY CLEARANCE.
IT'S TERRIFYING TO THINK BRENNAN
STILL HAS ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION.
HE IS AN EXTREMIST AND SHOULD
NOT HAVE SECURITY CLEARANCE.
SENATOR RAND PAUL SAID JOHN
BRENNAN SHOULD NOT HAVE A
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
THEN IT WAS EVOKED AND WE
ASSUMED THAT WAS THE END OF THE
STORY.
A YEAR LATER BRENNAN STILL AS A
SECURITY CLEARANCE?
HOW?
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IGNORED THE
PRESIDENT'S ORDERS.
HE WAS ELECTED BY VOTERS AND
THEY WERE NOT.
ALL LEGITIMATE POWER IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH FLOWS FROM HIM
AND THE ELECTION HE WON.
HIS EMPLOYEES DON'T CARE.
BUREAUCRATS WIELD THE REAL
AUTHORITY.
WE DECIDED TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE CALLED OVER TO THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
WE WERE TOLD THAT BRENNAN NO
LONGER HAS ACCESS TO CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, THAT MEANS THE
ADMINISTRATION SENT A LETTER TO
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES EXPLAINING
THAT BRENNAN NO LONGER HAS A
NEED TO KNOW.
THAT SOUND REASSURING, BUT IT'S
A MIRAGE.
IT MEANS NOTHING.
BUREAUCRATS CAN IGNORE THAT
LETTER.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WAS UNDERMINED BY HIS OWN
STAFF.
HE GAVE THEM A DIRECT ORDER.
IN THEIR PASSIVE AGGRESSIVE WAY
THEY REFUSED TO CARRY IT OUT.
EVERY TIME THAT HAPPENS OUR
DEMOCRACY ERODES.
THAT'S FINE WITH OFFICIAL
WASHINGTON.
IF HOLDING ELECTIONS MEAN DONALD
TRUMP WINS POWER THEY ARE
AGAINST HOLDING ELECTIONS.
NANCY PELOSI SAID HER GOAL IS
NOT TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
HER GOAL IS TO PUT HIM IN
PRISON?